before you go to bed in the night there
are certain things that you need to take
care of one simple thing can be just a
shower always to shower before go to bed
it'll make a lot of difference have you
noticed if you're very tense and anxious
whatever just the shower you came out it
feels like almost the burden has been
taken away from you have you not noticed
this so it's not just about washing the
skin
a whole lot of things happen when water
flows over your body the shower is a
very rudimentary Beauty
because over 70 percent of your body is
actually water if you run water over it
a certain purification happens which is
Beyond cleaning the skin